لانه في نقطه خطيره جدا
العقل الدراسي في الشريعه الاسلاميه في
الجامعات عقل تجزيئي
مش عقلي كله بمعنى ان العقل التجزيئي ما
يعرفش يخرج بنظريه ما يعرفش يخرج بفكره
جديده لانه حبيس الجزئيات فلان قال كذا
وفلان قال كذا في المساله دي لكن المفترض
ان الدراسه تنتقل الى العقل الموضوعي الى
العقل الكلي الذي يصبح فيما بعد حاكما على
الجزئيات
العقل الكلي يعني عنده القواعد العقليه
عنده الفلسفه عنده اصول الفقه عنده اصول
الحديث عنده اصول التاريخ ثم يحاكم ما
يقال فاذا قرا كتابا زي تفسير الطبري
تاريخ الطبري قرا اي كتاب في كتب السنه في
كتب الفقه يستطيع ان يحكم على الجزيئات
انه هذا مقبول وهذا غير مقبول
احنا ما عندناش كده الان احنا عندنا الان
لاطار التجزيئي يعني انت لما انا عندما
اقول للطلبه اعرض الحديث على القران يعني
اعرض الحديث على القران كليك قضيه كليه ما
بيقولكش اعرضه على قضيه جزئيه فالعقل
التجزيء ايضا عقل مشوش مبعثر في يا سيدي
كلمه يقول العلماء من قديم يقول هناك عالم
او باحث عقله اكبر من علمه
وهناك باحث علمه اكبر من عقله يقرا كثيرا
في الجزئيات لكن في نعمه ما عندوش رؤيه
اللي فرق محمد شوف ساله رشيد رضا رشيد رضا
تلميذ محمد عبده
هل كان الاستاذ الامام اعلم اهل زمانه قال
له بل كان اقلهم علما
لكنه كان انفعهم بالقليل
عنده معلومات قليله يعمل فكره يعمل عقله
يخدم المجتمع الثاني حافظ حواشي كتب كثيره
جدا لكن الانتاج الاثر ذات محمد عبده ساب
مدرسه فيها شلتوت والمراغي تيار كامل
مستمر